Hey youtubers it's Charlie! we gotta
talk all about attack on gorilla City
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet.
Welcome to the jungle! There were so many
planet of the apes references in this.
I'm so happy with what they did and I know a
lot of you expected some of the fight
scenes to be a little bit longer but it's
just a prelude to part two which is
going to be next week, so if you're new
to the channel I do flash videos every
week be sure to subscribe to get
everything I even do giveaways too I'll
explain that at the end of the video so
let's do top 10 WTF and comic-book
easter eggs i'm so happy with this
two-parter you have to consider it like a
two-hour TV movie just because so much
and let me know if you guys think the
audio is ok i changed it just a little
bit so it should sound a little better
another tanker Rilla city explainer so
we learned that the city of super smart
age babe captured Harrison wells you
actually learned that they said this
cryptogram the same way the team flash
and a cryptogram into the multiverse
that's how they got HR to come to their
earth in the first place like you send a
coded message but the ones that the
gorilla scent is super advanced so it
gives you an idea of just how smart they
are
it's not there is smarter than humans is
that they're super smart and they have
psionic abilities meaning that they can
control other people so they're a huge
threat and obviously the whole thing is
a big long con on garage park but the
way they disseminate information through
the episode you'll learn that they
wanted to tease Harrison wells capture
him used him to get to earth one leading
us into number 9 trying to avert the
future future news headline city
recovering from guerrilla attack
maybe if we can change more things we
can save virus but i really like this
reverse-flash idea so there was a lot of
shoutouts to the Harrison wells
reverse-flash from season one
he is the one that said that taking
action to avoid some big future
catastrophe only leads to something
equally as bad happening
that's why you don't change the past but
team flash this season has learned you
might be able to change small things but
the really big things usually end up
happening in different ways even if they
didn't go down the way you thought they
would just one of many callbacks to the
reverse-flash in the episode very using
his signature move to take down soul of
our garage referencing and father taught
me well
always thinking ahead so the
reverse-flash of season one is still
very present even though we haven't seen
him in a long time they put the team
together i love all the Indiana Jones
shoutouts planet of the apes tell me
you're going to Planet of the Apes
there's no way I'm staying behind the
whole thing here
julia is worried about Caitlin I know
they're teasing some sort of
relationship but he is really concerned
for her in a genuine way I love the way
they tagged out at the end to you should
fear me
well why don't we hear each other over a
giant state together
number eight welcome to the jungle the
gates of gorilla City so in addition to
this thing looks like a really awesome
wide shot giant star wars guns and roses
easter egg
it is so much fun how they cram all
those references and callbacks the
season
two in those opening moments before they
get thrown in the cells like she
remembers meeting earth to killer frost
what happened her know she is super dead
now so you see Kaitlyn is starting to
get more and more worried
so even though it seems like they're
taking a lot of steps to prevent Caitlyn
from becoming killer frost she's
actually more and more using her powers
in small ways which is making it worse
progressively so it sounds like one of
those things that we're gonna ride that
no matter what like whatever ends up
happening Caitlyn's going to keep having
to use her powers to help her friends
and she's going to get closer and closer
to killer frost so I already did a video
about the flash prophecy about someone
betrayed the team to talk a little bit
about killer frost cisco stuff will add
a link at the end of the video number
send way back on earth one Wally Jesse
teaming up by restoring in the lock it
down
this is all the prelude to her staying
on earth one but you get the sense that
she's super bummed out and she's not
really sure what Wally thinks that for a
figure it all out
it's all relationship stuff so easy like
this or you hate it is totally cool if
you're not down with this but they just
want to let you know that they're going
to be cool with each other and she's not
jealous or anything it's just that she's
not sure what while they think suffer
because she's just worried that he's
more in love with being a speedster and
of course he's like all that bull crap
so I do like the character development
that wallet just here getting I'm a
really big fan of Jesse quicks character
so it'll be interesting to see how they
use the next couple weeks just be
careful if you've been watching the
behind-the-scenes stuff please don't
post spoilers in the comments back to
earth to number six Grodd captures the
team and explains the grand plan
kill-or-be-killed sola bars going to
come to your earth he wants to attack
you i love people like Caitlyn because
they help me I never want to see harm
come to them so this is what you have to
do you have to kill him in the arena and
you start to wonder because broad is one
of flashes biggest enemies in the comic
what's going on here is there some big
twist behind this and it becomes a
little more clear number five when solar
bar mr. Keyes David enters I was so
happy with keith david being cast on the
show he has one of the most awesome
voices ever of course he should be so
levar so he walks in his super surprised
to see team flash like he did not expect
more humans so he accepts flashes
challenge in number for flash vs soul
bar is a pretty epic by i know a lot of
you
wanted to go longer but just remember
that this is sort of the prelude to the
bigger part 2episode which is next week
so they were going to waste too much
time with this arena fight but they just
want to let you know what a badass most
of these gorillas are so large very
smart he has all the same powers is
Gorilla Grodd and there's sort of a
dichotomy so great is this really evil
power hungry gorilla soul of ours the
wise one who doesn't want to attack
humans but it's also very wary of them
to he would kill them if he needed to
but he doesn't see quartz the way that
God does he doesn't care about revenge
it was so funny watching soul of our
just shut Barry down all is normal
tricks were working try the Lightning
throat till he had to fight dirty
using a reverse last trick that might
come back again later in the season
doing things that you never thought you
would do learning from your enemy's
tactics so just remember that for when
he's fighting sabotage later that season
look at the work on his shield here this
is so crazy in the Spiritist to actually
the statute spear tips when they entered
the city look like flash lightning bolts
so the craftsmanship is amazing and you
learned from the fights that the flashes
head with Grodd and the past two solovar
has all those skills and look how
quickly he anticipates the flashes next
move like he can just time him down to a
tee
so he thought that Barry was being super
Beta or he went down too fast
this is just them showing you that solar
bar is that much smarter than everyone
else so the flash runs real fast
that doesn't make him a genius he's only
a genius for 30 minutes at a time and he
did not read any books about fighting
super guerillas when he entered at arena
will probably see some better
strategizing when we get around to part
2 of this episode
usually the team has to come together
before they can take down something this
big gorilla grodd is one of the biggest
threats the baseball season next to
sabotage the only thing that makes
avatar worse is that he has knowledge of
the future and he just flat out faster
than all of the speedsters put together
a number three Grodd reveals his true
plant he is pissed that blast did not
kill solovar mostly because even though
he's in charge now
solovar still alive to challenge him it
will probably be key to defeating rod in
episode 2 next week so the bars always
really important for fighting ground
products that have been a lot of issues
a lot of stories where the flashes
thought God by himself with the help of
other people he even teamed up with the
rose but the thing is it for a lot of
those stories sola bar was dead he came
back during black as night during a
brief period but silver bar is the
person that you want on your team if
you're going to be fighting garage
we'll see what they do with them Grodd
made all those references about the hell
that he was living in living under soul
of ours rule living in one of soul of
ours cages so in a reversal of that he
made the throne soul of our into a cage
of his own the plans revealed rods been
running a long con
he wants revenge against people in earth
one that put in cages so he's going to
burn central city to the ground
number two until team flash is able to
escape by make believing that the areas
that remember keelan edit user powers
again meaning that our killer frost
condition is getting worse
even though she didn't have to actually
kill somewhat that would have been
crossing the edge maybe that the hat tip
for the future she accidentally killed
someone in that makes her become killer
frost but how crazy was it when cisco
suggested that they kill him on the only
one that can get you back so you have to
kill me he actually meant that but
that's not something that you can come
back from so of course everyone is like
hard path we are not killing anyone
so they try to trick garage and i love
how they get home and everything is
super night Jesse quick even says that
she's going to stay they get the kiss
with Wally even iris Elsberry I don't
know how you can be so positive and he's
like I know we can defeats avatar now
because we want so hard
Julian probably had the biggest
rule-breaking moment when he said they
were very smart but we were smarter like
the minute you call out a victory like
that you know that they're going to take
it right back and yank the rug out from
under you
so number one post-credits teaser God
has earth 19 gypsy he's wearing his
armor there is a legion of gorillas
ready to roll out and they are coming to
attack central city that's actually the
name of the next episode attack on
central city so it is going to be crazy
the whole thing here with gypsy is they
don't let you know about the twist after
the big twist like oh my gosh she's
helping them so I don't think she's evil
she wouldn't want to destroy central
city so either he's blackmailing her or
he's out right controlling her
mine because just because cisco and just
be happy all those powers doesn't mean
they're not susceptible to being taken
over by garage let me know in the
comments though what was your guys
favorite moment i love the way they
plotted out garage parking this episode
how he seems like he's the one that's in
trouble and needs help but then revealed
that he was behind this grand plan all
along
always one step ahead of the flash so
even though the TV show it's called dust
/ really Grodd is the main character of
these two episodes so it's going to be
epic to see how they take them down in
part two
maybe it'll have something to do with
solovar and it'll all come back around
to the idea of them being able to change
events change things for the better save
people without completely being able to
escape those future headlines so they
can always change small things but there
are some things that they probably will
not be able to change so the gorillas
will smash up Central City really good
but they might be able to save some
people from dying but it was a great
episode is going to be fun to see Jesse
quick on the TV show every week for at
least the next couple weeks I don't know
exactly how long she's going to stay but
what's going to happen for the next
couple of videos as the schedule is
going to be a little bit different
I'll do a blast trailer video next and
i'll do legends of tomorrow and then I'm
probably going to wait to do my arrow
episode till thursday morning there's a
new round of the injustice giveaway
going on right now all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video is for a copy of
the game
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner Malachi McNeil please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so i can get your contact details so
i'll post that flash trailer video
tomorrow morning while you wait for that
you can click here for Wonder Woman
areas and you can click here for all
about this savitar prophecy
thank you so much watching let's high five  i'll
see you guys in the next video!